Speaker 1: One thing that's really popular among
Republicans right now is to take positions and
support policy ideas that are really common
to parts of the world that we often don't
aspire to be like. By we, I mean these very
Republicans don't. And also that are playing
coy with the ideas and policies of extreme
dictators and authoritarians and the latest
ideas that Donald Trump has been on a kick about
executing drug dealers, putting drug dealers to
death. Trump has now started fundraising off
of this idea. He talks about it regularly at
his rallies. So let's start there. Here's just
one example. Trump has seized on this because I
guess some in the crowd seem to kind of like it.
Speaker 2: They kill 500 people during a lifetime,
and I think it's much worse than that.
I think that's only what we hear about.
It would stop it if you didn't get it down
75, 80, 90% from day one. I'd be surprised.
And these committees that they set up, it's
laughable. It's a horrible thing. We would
solve that problem so fast. And I'm calling
on Republicans and Democrats immediately to
institute to get to Washington and institute
the death penalty for drug dealers. You
will no longer have a problem. There it is.
Speaker 1: Kill the drug dealers. And as you
all probably know by now, from years of following
this guy, when he sees us on something, he really
seizes on it. And of course, the ideal thing would
be, can I make some money off of it? And indeed,
Donald Trump is now sending out fundraising emails
about this. Donald J. Trump Ecom sent out an email
called The Death Penalty. And when you look inside
the email, it's another one of these fake polls.
And what I mean by that is it looks like a poll.
They want you to take a survey, but it's actually
a fundraising pitch. Do you agree that drug
dealers should face the death penalty? Yes or
no? Thank you. Team Trump, take the survey now.
You know, capital punishment for drug trafficking
is something that some countries do have now.
It's rarely because you got caught selling some
pot on the street. But there are countries
that have extremely severe punishments for
drug dealing and drug trafficking. But I'm going
to tell you what some of those countries are,
and they are typically countries that Republicans
say are backwards. This is what they say.
Republicans say these are backwards countries
that the US should not be trying to be like. These
are the countries that have the death penalty,
capital punishment for drug trafficking. They
include Bahrain and Bangladesh, Egypt, Iran and
Iraq, Jordan, Kuwait, Libya, North Korea, Qatar,
Pakistan, Syria. You get the idea. These are not
exactly countries that Republicans say should be
the guiding light for how the United States should
operate. And the sort of I don't know that I want
to call it funny. The sad thing to some degree
is that many of the ideas that Republicans like
are only seen in these authoritarian type
countries, often Muslim authoritarian countries.
You know, when right wingers of sorts sort of are
titillated by this idea of Christian nationalism,
a Christian version of Sharia law, and a total
melding of their religion and civil government.
The countries that are like that tend to be
countries Republicans don't like. I mean,
it's it's Saudi Arabia, it's Iran. It's you get
the picture. And so when you say to Republicans,
the models for what you're talking about are
these countries they have. Well, no, no, no,
no. Those countries are no good. But here it would
be good if we did it. But it's because this is
this would be with Christianity that we would
do it. They're doing it with Islam. Shockingly,
more and more Republican ideas sound like
the ideas of these authoritarian, dictatorial
countries. And now Donald Trump has seized on
let's kill drug dealers. And by the way, this
idea of every drug dealer kills 500 people. It's
absurd. It's truly absurd. Nobody has been able
to actually find any evidence backing that up. And
now Donald Trump is trying to fundraise off of it.